so what there's such a a lot of people
on my channel um didn't grow up with two
parent homes and that's why they're
really enamored when they hear me like
talk about have like growing up in our
family
what advice do you have for young men
that want to because my audience is
mostly men so what advice do you have
for young men that are feeling lost and
like want to be successful in life
well i i guess it's kind of like it's
like even i'd say to you the same thing
is that not saying you're lost but
i i don't have um
like do what your passion is
and if you do your passion no matter
what it is it will lead you to
success
and if nothing else it would lead you to
happiness on your own or happiness with
money is still going to lead you down a
road
that will make you satisfied
and so like when you told me you want to
do a youtube career tic tac thing i
thought you were nuts but i mean i'm not
i'm serious i i'm so anti-social media
that just because i just don't deal with
it but it was your passion
so because it's your passion a 100
percent back you man i think it's great
i think you're chasing what you want to
chase it's the best thing in the world
chase your dream
and i feel like i did i did the same
thing i changed my dream and i was i was
good at it and same thing you'd be good
at it so whatever you do if you do it
with passion and you put the time and
effort into it you'll be good and that's
what most people don't realize is that
you can't just give up i mean you've
been doing this for several years and
now you're starting to go because you
followed your passion it takes time
takes effort and when you do that i
don't care what it is i don't care if
it's walking dogs
whatever you love do it do it well and
figure out a way after that to make it
so you can do it for a living
so yeah hannah adding on to that i think
that um
so many people allow fear to drive them
and that's probably one of the things
that our family does best is just you
know it doesn't like just drown out the
noise and you know when people are lost
out there they're lost because they're
listening to the noise and if they just
drown it out
um you know it's it's i had a revelation
about something that really
kind of has a dark start but it's a good
thought is that i was thinking about i
saw a drunk driver one day and i thought
it was amazing like all the people that
that person missed they missed a
pedestrian a bicyclist a couple of their
cars and i was like wait
the odds of them hitting somebody are
probably pretty low like in general
but
we all focus on the the most horrid part
of it which is horrible i'm not taking
away from that but i'm saying that that
we all focus on all of the things that
can go wrong instead of just focusing on
what can go right
and most things every single day go
right but people don't think about that
they spend all their energy thinking
about what could go wrong
and you know and and i think we're in
this world that people are afraid
they're just afraid of everything just
stop being afraid
and just go live
yeah that's something that i think is
unique to our family too because
everyone has like such a go-getter
attitude
and um
that's that's i think the best piece of
advice dad you've ever given me because
otherwise i'd probably still be working
in sales like that would have been the
safe route but i'm like a million like
you guys see it a million times happier
doing this
rather than that soul-crushing copyright
wait what again are you doing oh sorry
yeah i still don't get it i'm not gonna
lie this is what i do except i argue
i'm just like i usually am arguing with
people
are we arguing about who's the best
sibling which is clearly me me me
[Laughter]
that's chas
yeah
and then what so then another question
from the chat is what advice do you have
from someone that
wants a big family and wants to raise a
lot of kids
i love this one can i oh sure
um
again it's like
just do it and most people they have
kids and they stop living and i watch i
watch person after mom after mom after
mom and they just stop they stop living
they stop going and you know when you
know adam was three weeks old i think
when we took him on a nine country trip
in europe and you know he got his
passport on the first like on the way
home from the hospital and we just did
it and and people are like well this
might happen that it might but it might
not and so you know having a lot of kids
doesn't cost
like the same amount of money
exponentially and i remember when you
guys were little and we would spend you
know we get our credit card bill at the
end of every month and it was a certain
amount of money and then as we had more
kids it didn't really change because you
stopped going out to eat you start you
know handed clothes down you can afford
to do a lot more and
the value and just the joy that was in
your four walls you didn't have to go
pay for it outside those four walls and
so yeah is it hard there's a lot of hard
days but you know when i'm 51 years old
51 i always say i'm 52. who rounds up i
don't know
um you know i'm 51 years old some of the
best gifts my parents ever gave me
wasn't you know wasn't an education or
anything else it was my siblings and so
you know i hope that
when you look at your life and you're 51
years old i hope you feel the same way
that it wasn't the trips or the car or
the you know whatever it was you know
you're the people you're surrounded by
so what do you think dad
i'm sorry um tips for raising a lot of
kid and having a big family oh i don't
know don't don't don't take too much out
of it
don't i get decided don't think
everything is a crisis dying the walls
are falling in just sit down and hey
that's how you notice guys like most
times i don't right sometimes i react
don't get me wrong but for the most part
i just like okay
what's going on now who's yelling at who
who's it now
so i mean you guys and i spend a lot of
my life you guys may not think that but
being like a peacemaker i do my best
maybe too much because eva pushes it a
little too far
what do i do
that's the point you answer my question
in writing uh what do you do okay
but the point is you just gotta not
not everything is not a crisis life is
just
it's just a sit back figure it out
get through it go to the next point and
so just didn't enjoy it try to enjoy it
i
mean
don't be in like a hot studio in the
middle of sorry
yeah we're all melting yeah
london doesn't have to have ac i don't
know what you guys are doing out here
yeah it's the hottest day of the year
and like how long
like forever
but
being organized helped too
if you have your health
there's nothing else i'm watching my my
siblings like to start dropping
because the health you must have your
health and so if you have that if you
don't lose a limb lose a foot little leg
you you can always get through it you
can't start again you can always do
something it's health that's the problem
i mean it just is i mean i'm watching it
so seriously now i watch my sister my
brother my other sister i mean i think
it's four or five now that just it's
just it's sad
and there's and that's the one thing you
must maintain and if you do that
everything else doesn't matter you go
live in a beach then somewhere if you
have to but
if you don't have that and you pain all
the time and then life sucks i just
watch it no that's the one thing i
always say about you when i'm like
telling people stories i'm like my dad
can stay calm in anything and like
whenever i'm freaking out about
something you're so good at like
bringing me down to earth i mean like
it's not that big of a deal calm down
you're not dying your house is on fire
don't worry about it
even like when i was here i lost
everything i lost like everything on a
train like my id my wallet like
literally everything and i'm like crying
and he's and you were just like you're
fine just order new ones
adam lost his laptop the other day
yesterday got stolen and then a day it
sucks but it is what it is i blame dad
for that i wouldn't have taken it out of
my bag but yeah it was my fault i